ينصح القائمون على مركز السيطره على
الامراض في امريكا البالغين الاصحاء
بتناول ما لا يزيد عن 2500 مليغرام من
الصوديوم يوميا الا ان دراسات تفيد بان
الفرد يتناول عاده اكثر من ذلك بكثير وهذا
الامر غير صحي لان الملح هو السبب الرئيسي
للاصابه بارتفاع ضغط الدم وامراض القلب
ويعتقد خبراء ان قله من الناس يقرؤون
محتويات الملصقات الطبيه الخاصه بالصوديوم
اذ ان التركيز يتمحور فقط حول الدهون
والسعرات الحراريه لذا يجب مراعاه مكونات
العبوات جيدا من جانبه اعد مركز السيطره
على الامراض لائحه بالاغذيه التي يجب
الانتباه الى مكوناتها ومن بينها حساء
الطماطم خصوصا المعلب منها ورغم شعبيتها
الا ان البيتزا المثلجه تندرج ضمن اللائحه
ايضا اذ تحتوي الحصه الواحده على نصف معدل
الصوديوم الواجب تناوله يوميا ولا بد من
الانتباه الى ما يضاف عاده على السلطات
فبعض التوابل قد تحتوي على ما يقارب 500
ملغرام من الصوديوم وهناك بعض انواع من
الخبز التي تحتوي على 2 و10 مليغرامات من
الصوديوم في كل شريحه وعليه يشدد الاطباع
على اهميه مراعاه كميات الملح المتناوله
يوميا لان الصوديوم مفيد لنسبه الانسولين
في الجسم اضافه الى الغده
الدرقيه